hi I made it and I'll be representing
Alaska the National Geographic Bee now
i'm going to show you around about my
hometown a creature this is my home as
you can see it is regular house not
anything i'm going to go hitch up the
dog team as you can see an anchorage we
use normal cars too just like people in
the lower 48 let's go out west
I am at an overlook about 20 miles away
from our house it overlooks the connect
arm which is an arm of the Cook Inlet
over my left shoulder you can see the
Chugach mountains which we frequently go
on hikes in and downtown Anchorage my
right you can see the Talkeetna
mountains which are about a hundred
miles away from Anchorage and behind
them is the Alaska Range which you
should know Mount McKinley is the
highest mountain in North America is
part of the Alaska Range and you could
see it on a clear day but it's cloudy
and over here is sleeping lady which
kind of looks like a lady sleeping
along with 250,000 people Anchorage is
also home to a significant population of
other species
here we are about a 10 minute drive from
our house in East Anchorage the name
Alaska from the aliens word eliska which
can be translated as the great land it's
a wall chosen a don't do you think
ah it's a wonderful Alaskan spring day
it's the perfect day to study my
geography
you